S NO ID WHA
FOREIN'SOUNCEMENT AS L. FRDMROU
TH DOING SOMETHING CRAZY
ON STARE HIM IN THE
STERN
ENGAGING IA
AS DIRTY DEALCK TO THNE
EVD BUT WOULD PUTIN HAVE  OUSTEB
THE UNABCAHIS WALY KNOT.
N JOINOWF SEVEG "THE WORLD I" YP
THEIOWN ARMS OARCHING
SOON T D
THE QUESONS JU
G LIINE HAEN OVER BY LEADERSHIP.
THIN ,  AIMED AART OF RUSSIA.
E  WN NAZI
THE OTHER SIDEF DAGGER IS PO
IT W CII.LAND.
IT WASD ADOLHITLER AND 5ION RUN
ING BELIEVE A WO YOU'RONLY D NO,
G E QUICKEST WAYOUT OF THIS UNTE
S TOS  AS THE WAR WASN'TE OF
THEY WERE SAFEEM,
AND DOHING
BUCALLEDRVISTS PEOPL E
BLOWREAN INEN
AS DO U THINK THATE REPORTS SUD
S AREAS.
D THATF HEOE WIL
FOSTER MORE RE IURIO O
BAONS,ICAL IT'TAKING.
PUTIN, AND OFFERS ICT,
E FRONT LINEORIX
TIF YOU
DE'LL YOU.
VI
MIDDLE CRSSCOWININCE THIS WA
UN W EVE WHERE
UKRAINE IS, HALF,
R OT BTHE  CLAESF
THUSSIAN TO HI
A OTHERE  FOR
3000 TO BEF THINGS WERE GOING W
>> THEY MUST K
OMHICE
,0O 0 KIND
ULATION THAT HAS ESBUST POPULATS
MA BARGAIN WITH TIN, YOUET US GE
ECONOMICETTER OFF ANCAN DOO SIMH
GOING DOOR TORN THE REFERENDUM
WE R CRI
I THINK THE VOTE WAS 97% ED.PRG
ESTHAT TSE
REGIONS TO PART OF
RUSSIA, TH IS
RES -DMI
PREST BASHAR AAS
99OF VOTES PRESIDENTWO
E YOU.
HE SAID THEI AREASE VASTLY POPUW
IT JUST AS YOUHAE IS TO HAVE THA
AND, OH,TH
EUROPEANS WH RECOGNIZE THA
TURN OURYOU.
TH PROBLEMATL SATOANT YOU SOMET
MISERABLAN AS THEY
MIGHT BE THEN SATO
SUGGESTING THAT IN THEURN ISCH
VERY BUTHATH B ABOUTTHE ED HER
HOME PARTIRLY WI
REPUBL
>> ABSOLUTELY.I THINK THE REPUBT
FUNDING FORAINE.REPUBLICANEMTHLA
E  BA REAL I
PRLEVEL OF
FINANCIAL SUPPORT.
FRIEDMAN, SO PUTTOGETHER, ATTRAR
ALL-OUT SSIA
IS THE
SOMESETTLEMENT
IT'S POSSIBLE?
Y KNOW,, I'
WARY ABOUT D
DAILY UIE POINT IF THE
PRESSURE T EUROPEAN
UNION O FRACTUREND
T THERG E TO
BEATZENSAT THEE , YO
JUST HAVSU
E DE
THEIR'SHA
DECA. HOPE,T SO POI